- Alright I guess
that just goes to show
that you can lead
a horse to water
but you can't
make him butt chug.
We'll see you next time on
Every Damn Day.
- Okay that's a cut guys.
Amazing, everybody gets an Emmy.
- Alright those scripts are due
by the end of the day
so let's take a quick lunch,
work through it.
- Cool, thank you.
- Me so hungy.
I'm going to eat
like four lunches after this.
(loud chewing)
- Is Jordan's chewing
distracting anyone?
- Yes.
- Maybe he's not chewing,
maybe he's teething?
- What happened?
- You chew like a vulture.
- I'm just eating my launch.
- You're doing a lot more
than that to it.
- I'm going to punch you
in the throat.
- Fine. I guess I'll just eat
the soup I got instead.
- Cool.
Are you chewing on soup?
- If teeth are the problem
I can take them off your mouth.
- Wow, I guess soup is bad too.
- Just open the bag
or I'll shove it down the hole
I punch in your throat.
- You know what I was trying
to open the bag
slowly out of respect
for you guys
but I guess lunch
is illegal now.
- You want to suck on a peanut?
- Excuse me?
- I eat loud too.
So I eat when no one
is around.
And I suck on a peanut
to the curb the between time.
- Oh ok yeah sure thanks.
- Be good.
- Sorry my ringtone
is a loud chewing sound.
I thought it'd be funny
but it's not funny.
- It's kind of funny.
- A little funny.
Is this another?
- No, no he's choking.
He's choking!
- Come on!
I don't know what I'm doing.
- Let me, here. He's gone.
Time of death, right now.
- Why is it so loud in here?
- Jordan's just eating.
- Oh, carry on.
- Jordan?
He's dead.
- What?
Jordan is dead and Nate
will not be happy about this.
- Do something!
Watch out everybody,
watch out.
Defibrillate him, Chris!
Cake?
- Pluto is a planet again.
- So cool. Wow!
- Yeah please.
- Pass it down. Cheers!
(loud chewing)
- Oh I'm sorry.
- It's OK.
I think we all deserve
to chew loudly today.